Edward I have some questions about the
novel that Jonathan Lethem wrote but I
want ask about another book that clearly
was part of this film and that is the
power broker by Robert Caro for people
don't know Depp on that did you I picked
up on that what does the power broker
about and why is that how did that book
start to intersect with your adaptation
of Jonathan Latham's novel my first
introduction to Robert Moses was was the
Byrnes film on New York the documentary
on New York and that I you know everyone
in New York has sort of heard of Robert
Moses but he is this shadowy the shadowy
dark Darth vader-like figure who who it
still shocks me the degree to which that
history is hidden and and Karos book is
obviously kind of the definitive look at
him
I think that Jonathan Jonathan's novel
is about Lionel and the orphans working
for minna but it takes place in the 90s
and it and it's it's really a it's this
it's a character study it's this
beautiful portrait of this guy in his
mind and everything but we it not to get
too into the weeds but it's a very
surreal it has a very surreal sort of
meta 50s kind of a quality to it it has
a Chandler kind of a feeling to it and
we just felt we felt that it was easier
to play it straight if we actually said
it in the 50s it it it we didn't want it
to be ironic and we didn't want Lionel
to be like a running gag so the 50s felt
more true to the tone of the book and
then then that let us open up into a
wider sort of historical canvass in a
way so when you set the story from
present day when the novel was written
to 1957 a couple things change one of
the things is that Lionel's relationship
to his own symptoms he doesn't
understand in the novel there's actually
a pamphlet that Lionel's given
understanding Tourette's but in your
movie he doesn't have the vocabulary the
people around him don't understand what
it is
that he has so how does that change him
as a character especially in relation to
others yeah it's a good question I think
that that was part of the did his
emotional isolation and his his
loneliness was not we didn't it's a
great part of Jonathan's book but to me
you know again a lot of it came from the
decision to set it in the time that the
book feels like but then it changes a
lot like and the idea but to us the idea
that he doesn't even know what he has is
even more lonely so it and it people
calling him freak show his best friends
calling him freak show didn't feel very
contemporary to us so it was it was it's
hard to explain why the book feels like
it's it's set in that era but it does
Gugu if you went through the novel and
looked for information about Laura you
would be frustrated because she's not in
the novel so when you're having your
first conversations with Edward about
this character that he's created but
exists in this story where do you start
what were the first thing she said
should I read the book and say yeah I
mean my first introduction to this this
whole world was Edward script and you
know I normally love to do my research
and go go back and you know look to the
book and I did look at the book but
obviously there was nothing of my
character there but that was kind of
liberating in a sense because the script
was so rich I mean really you know
the screenplay you know the the dialogue
all of these characters are so sort of
beautifully drawn from Lionel's
perspective and then it was as I say you
know a nice opportunity for me to kind
of research New York in the period you
know I'd never been to Harlem before I
researched this film which was a treat
and you know I've always loved jazz and
you know a chance for me to kind of you
know research the world in which Laura
comes from the Jazz era and and that
music was it's really fun for me as well
I wanna ask you about collaborating with
Daniel because there are a lot of
different influences in this movie about
the sound there's jazz there
Tom York there is what Daniel is gonna
bring so what were the first
conversations you have with Daniel about
the sound of the film and how it would
include these jazz elements both kind of
as a theme and both in performance I
think you could say as an umbrella
statement about this whole film there
was always sort of what I would call
test conversations with people you and
me say like we're gonna make a a big New
York noir period piece like LA
Confidential but imagine Rain Man at the
center of it you know a certain number
of people's eyes cross and they make
excuses and head for the door and those
are not going to be your people other
people are intrigued and and those are
the people with when you say I want to
mash up Radiohead and Bop jazz from the
50s a lot of people also say like that
sounds like an unholy mess but the
people who don't and who like the those
those that peanut butter and chocolate
together become the people you want to
collaborate with and I and I you know I
think Daniel and I met in a bar in
London and about 1:30 in the morning he
had just wrapped recording a very
complicated score and I sort of floated
cautiously that I liked
Vangelis the score of Chariots of Fire
because it had that synth modernist
feeling combined a period story on a
period story with a classical thing and
it's but Vangelis is is one of those
things you some people might really like
flip their noses and go you did not just
reference men jealous you know but I
but fortunately Daniel said something
like but I was like that was really cool
because we were chatting I was so I just
finished this film literally recording
the very last thing of music I was so
hyperactive and completely exhausted at
the same time looking for free cocktail
a hand
so which hang away and then you know you
meet directors and they
dropped certain scores and there's all
the cool things to drop you know you
like a certain film scores everyone's
like I want it to be like that no one
ever drops chance of fire okay and what
that made me realize as soon as everyone
said that I was like oh this guy is
really interesting because for me it was
a director who really understood cinema
and he understood why Chasse if I is a
very exciting score because we all think
of it as a sort of I don't know car
slightly it's become so ubiquitous it
sort of becomes slightly a bit of a joke
you know like slow motion running and
but you think there's a period film and
someone has made that choice to put a
contemporary synthesizer score on it and
it's genius and it means like no one in
this room can ever think of anyone
running in slow motion without hearing
that thing and we kind of think it's
funny and it is kind of funny at the
same time that is like the power of
cinema when you create an image or you
create a moment that is seared in
everyone's everyone's mind and that for
me is like everything I want to do in
film music is those sequences and to
have someone look beyond the kind of
like the sort of sort of perceived joke
of chats if I'm and see what a great
piece of cinema is I was like holy [ __ ]
this guy's really [ __ ] cool right
[ __ ] I've got this movie now because I
was I was exhausted and I can't didn't
want to do the movie knocks I didn't
want to do it I just wanted to have like
more than like five hours of sleep and
and then I was just like oh yeah I got
to do it and I was just so happy I'm so
pleased I did it because I was such a
great movie I think it was made such a
unique work and he let me be unique with
the score and he gave me that freedom to
to do something different and that's
what I felt when I first met him was I
thought here's someone who's gonna let
me do something special and he did so
I'm like really really grateful for that
and in them yes thank you in the in the
in the mem in the moments that you
remember I think the I will I have filed
in my treasure drawer like the look on
wynton marsalis his face when when
Daniel walked through the door and he
realized that that's who had written
this score that he had told me how much
he loved it and originally when it was
only going to play the music for the
band in the club but when I asked him if
he would do one or two key leads and we
sent him the whole score and then he
wrote me and said this is this is off
the hook like you should just let us do
all you should let me play all of it and
so Daniel came in and and when Daniel
walked in like I saw when double-take
and said you wrote you wrote this and he
said he's either like a bit of an idiot
basically well dad this is muted colours
Daniel Daniel was wearing I dressed like
a 1980s TV presenter from Britain which
unfortunately these days is due to
certain things in Britain not a very
good look good when you're acting with
Edward you're acting opposite an actor
and he's also the director he's also the
writer he's also the producer are you
able to remove most of those things and
just do a scene or what are the
conversations that you're having and
Edward as you're doing scenes with Gugu
how much of it is that's just is the
scene how do you check yourselves and
what is it like for you Gugu acting
opposite Edward what he's wearing
somebody has well you know when you're
in the scene you're in the scene I think
as actors like you know you I think
there is that moment where you you know
obviously Edwards an actor first and you
know when you're playing the scene you
do sort of forget that you're you're
working with your director you know
you're just two actors but for me I mean
it was it was amazing I mean it really
made it quite an intimate experience
because you know obviously there's not
101 conversations there's not many cooks
you know you are you know able to kind
of go to one person for many questions
and you know there is one vision and
it's very pure in a sense in terms of
the vision and you know I mean I was
constantly in awe of you know all of
their hats as you say that Edward was
wearing you know
on set and he was all over the place you
know really I mean in a good way I mean
I mean everywhere you know in a in a way
able to be in control of everything
which was so impressive and I think you
know obviously this amazing cast you
know phenomenal actors that you know
really rooted everything so so for me it
was it was an amazing you know fluid
experience and I think you know you're
all in it together in a sense so I loved
it
Edward goo-goo Daniel thank you much so
much for coming out